new fallout after a bloody weekend of
gun violence in America city's Georgia
Governor Brian Kemp calling in the
National Guard after 31 people were shot
in Atlanta and an 8-year old girl was
killed New York City is seen a spike in
crime shootings up 130 percent last
month compared to the same time last
year and a shocking video shows a father
gunned down crossing the street in broad
daylight with his six-year-old daughter
as he holds her hand Mayor Bill DeBlasio
under pressure to act the New York Post
telling him to do something to cover
very similar to the 1990s when Mayor
David Dinkins experienced a crime wave
all of this happening in the backdrop of
the defund the police movement relatives
of victims of gun violence are saying we
need more cops to prevent violence
we can't take money from the police
department we need the police you take
the police from there and we wind up
having less police officers in the
street let's detectives it's not gonna
work is a crime it's gonna get worse so
we're gonna go after the police officers
when they heard someone that look like
me we need to go after the people that
look like me that hurt people that look
like me and CNN's Don Lemon causing
controversy for lecturing actor Terry
Crews over black lives matter black
people need to hold other black people
accountable I said that's the same thing
if this is a the black America's version
of the me2 movement the black lives
matter movement was started because
there's talking about police brutality
if you want an all black lives matter
movement that talks about gun violence
in communities including you know black
communities then start that movement
with that name but that's not what black
lives matter is about so we'll get to
all of this one let me start with you so
we have the worst violent crime wave in
years just about days after city
officials took a billion dollars away
from the NYPD to appease some pretty
violent people that were outside
demanding that a billion dollars be cut
from the NYPD and now you have this
violent crime if you think back to the
1990s and how bad it got then
and how long it took to get things back
to a safe place so that New York City
could be that thriving safe City what do
you think should be done and what if the
papers are calling for Merida Blasio to
trying to finally do something will he
listen to those communities that are
asking for more police not fewer I think
they want better police Dana I think
that you know let's first of all I think
let's debunk this theory that somehow
there's this crime wave going on out
there the reality is crime is down in
the top 25 American cities 5% violent
crime is down 2% but what you have is
murder up about 16 percent in those 25
big American cities but note even as
we're talking about that you should keep
in mind that the murder rate that we're
experiencing now in a place like New
York is the same as it was in 2015 so
there's a lot of politics loaded into
the way that people are looking at what
I see is an explosion in terms of gun
violence and why is that
I think it's according to the experts
they pointed a lot of these gangsters a
lot of these drug dealers even a surge
in terms of domestic violence cases and
it's all really being accelerated by
easy access to guns we're looking at gun
violence so to me what we have here is a
mixed situation and it comes in the
aftermath of course of the George Floyd
case but I just really object to the
suggestion that the police aren't doing
their job or that somehow because of
increased scrutiny on police after the
George Floyd murder that police are back
enough that police aren't committing
these murders that are resulting in the
spike this is black on black crime in
poor neighborhoods done by hoodlums and
that's why I say of course every
community wants better policing but it's
not to be somehow used to dilute people
who are upset over police brutality in
America all right Emily let me ask you
about that because how do you you can't
solve other problems in terms of getting
even if you wanted to reform or better
policing if you are in the middle of a
situation where you have what I'm
looking at like some pretty shocking
statistics when it comes to increase in
crime
that's exactly right Dana this requires
a cohesion that a lot of these big
cities are missing to include two really
important elements which are enforcement
and follow-through so what is it matter
if we call for more cops or we bring in
the National Guard to augment local
departments if they're not able to make
any arrests or if they are but then
there isn't a prosecution or if there's
a prosecution but there aren't actual
deterrent consequences or judicial
discretion to say withhold bail or to
make an exception to a pre classified
nonviolent crime if he or she feels that
that situation warrants detainment were
extended custody and all of that falls
flat also if state and local leadership
aren't engaging in messaging of a zero
tolerance for violence and crime and
also support for law enforcement both
conceptual and also for the
rank-and-file I just see an overarching
problem that at every juncture there's a
lack of follow-through and so of course
it's going to embolden criminal behavior
both at the organized level that Wan
mentioned and also the local petty level
and it also stymies then that workable
solution that depends on all of those
interrelated factors that I just talked
about yeah sorry about that train is
like really loud today and it's early as
well Jesse down in Georgia where Brian
Kemp the governor has just called in the
National Guard and a state of emergency
in the state the Democratic Senate
candidate John Asaf is calling for gun
control not urging calm in the streets
well just to go back to what one said
one said crime is flat but homicides are
up well homicide is a crime wand and I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say that
homicide is probably the worst crime
there is so let's just get that straight
the other thing is everybody with a
brain knows that in a violent
neighborhood with a lot of drug
trafficking you need a strong police
presence because what the police do they
pull people over and they take illegal
guns and narcotics out of the car they
also serve Warren
and take dangerous guys off the streets
they use task force's informants and
Undercovers to stop drug and illegal gun
trafficking so when the police pull back
crime surges it also doesn't help when
there's a pandemic that squeezes drug
profits and the buy-side falls out onto
the bottom and prices drop so people are
fighting violently over a smaller piece
of the pie so now you have people
fleeing cities because of the pandemic
fleeing cities because of a crime wave
and you're gonna have what we saw in
Manhattan which is a gritty uncover
noble city where no one wants to live in
because it's a low quality of life
everybody knows blacks don't hate the
police and the police don't hate black
people yes there are issues but we can
deal with them through mutual respect
and I don't think it's too late for the
president to make a speech on the
teleprompter that says I feel the
suffering of certain sections of black
America I understand that police take a
lot of risk when they police these
dangerous streets I support both the
black community and the police community
and I will pour all of the resources of
the federal government to help save
every single American life because every
single American life is precious and
safety is not a political issue that
could go a long way and I don't think
it's too late for him to deliver a
speech like that also Greg I did want to
get back to this issue of the last night
when CNN's Don Lemon had actor Terry
Crews on and you ever have a situation
where a guest is invited on or you've
been a guest somewhere and the host
won't let you talk I will stop talking
and allow you to talk about what
happened last night on CNN
well the we didn't show that clip which
was Terry Crews it's an eloquent person
trying to make a very important point
that black lives matter isn't about
police brutality
it's about remaking America because they
keep talking about systemic racism
without specifics and what they're
trying to tell you is that we need to
throw everything out and I
not exaggerating this okay their leaders
will tell you this that they want to get
rid of capitalism patriotism and replace
it with identity politics which pits
race versus race the belief behind that
is that we are irredeemable as a country
and that we are guilty of deeds of our
ancestors it's incredibly poisonous but
he but Don Lemon couldn't let Terry make
that point so what he did is he race
explained to Terry Crews he he talked
over him and threw him because he was
terrified the viewers might actually
hear the truth and then he didn't want a
black man's voice that wasn't lemons and
it's a comparison worth noting
you know Terry Crews has been around he
played in the NFL he's an artist he's an
active he's an activist he's an actor
he's got five kids I mean lemon is just
a media mouthpiece and if you take the
contrast larger as this violence
explodes across the country and by the
way whan nobody is saying here that the
cops aren't doing his their jobs we're
saying that politicians and leaders
aren't letting them do their jobs it's a
very fine detail that you love to gloss
over back to Terry Crews right now what
is Terry Crews care about he cares about
the suffering in his community the real
problems the black on black crime but
Don Lemon is in the media so what does
he care about defunding the police the
destroy destroying monuments perceived
racism of products and people so he's
chasing the symbolic crap and Terry
Crews is actually trying to solve the
bigger problems and it makes you wonder
why is it that people like Don Lemon in
the media don't actually want to address
the real problems because maybe they
realize that those real problems are
caused by them ie Democrats and liberals
who run the cities who who who put out
these policies who make the police stand
back and prevent the police are doing
their jobs and helping the people in
minority of neighborhoods
maybe that's why Don Lemon doesn't want
to talk about it because it's the city's
Democrats cities that we're seeing hell
unleashed and he doesn't want he doesn't
want to have it their viewers to see the
truth and that's why he talked to over
Terry Crews right I'll never talk over
you that's for sure